[Music]
how do you deal with situations where
your words are likely to be used out of
context let's say and that's a situation
I've I've encountered well you see you
you encounter a situation like that very
frequently everyone does in their life
like if you're having a discussion with
someone you live with for example so
someone you have to be with for a long
time lover or boyfriend girlfriend wife
husband sibling for that matter
you're going to have contentious
discussions about how to move forward
and it's very frequently the case that
your words will be that you'll be straw
man your words will be taken out of
context the other person and you too
will try to win instead of trying to
solve the problem what you have to kind
of decide is well two things the first
thing is you're probably wrong in some
important way and you might think well
so what but no that's not it's not so
simple being wrong in some important way
is like having a map that doesn't
correspond to the streets if you're
wrong in some important way when you go
to where you're going you will get lost
and you might end up in the neighborhood
that you don't want to visit so it
actually matters if you're wrong and so
now if you're talking to someone who is
acting in opposition to you it's
possible that during your contentious
discussion they will tell you something
about how you're wrong that's accurate
now you're not going to be very happy
about that because like who wants to
discover that they're wrong but it's
better to figure out that your map is
inaccurate than it is to get lost and so
one of the things you have to remember
when you're discussing things with
people even if they're out to defeat you
let's say is that there is some
glimmering of the possibility that you
can walk away with more knowledge than
you walked in with and that's worth that
can be worth paying quite a price for
you know and so I've had the opportunity
to engage in public debate of an
exceptionally contentious nature for
let's say 18 months non-stop
fundamentally and the and it's been very
stressful but the upshot
that is that my arguments are in much
better shape than they were and I
shouldn't say that my thoughts are much
more refined than they were at the
beginning of this process not my
arguments are in better shape it's not
the right way to think about it is that
I'm clearer about what I know I can
articulate it better and that's all
forged in the heat of conflict if you're
discussing a contentious issue with
someone you love and that you have to
live with and put up with you want to
listen to them because what you really
want to do is establish a lasting peace
and you might even have to make their
arguments for them maybe you're more
verbally fluent than your partner which
doesn't mean by the way that you're
right more right just means you can
conduct you can construct better
arguments on the fly doesn't necessarily
mean that you're more accurate you might
have to help your partner formulate
their arguments so that you can really
get to grips with what it is that
they're trying to say so that you can
alter the way that you're constructing
your own narrative and your joint
narrative so that you're not butting
heads unnecessarily as you move forward
through life it's not a very good idea
to win an argument with your wife right
that isn't what you want because then
you have a defeated partner and the
defeated partner is not happy and the
defeated partner is often out to reclaim
the defeat and so as a strategy for
moving forward with someone who you're
going to wake up beside you know 5,000
times it's not a very advisable strategy
it's better to listen to flesh out the
argument on both sides and to see if you
can come to a mutually acceptable
negotiated settlement and that's the
case in most encounters in life if you
can manage that so but you know it's
easy to want to win one of the things I
do in my in my psychology seminar is I
assign papers to students and then I
extract out propositions from the papers
and their propositions that are
debatable and so then I outline the pro
side and I outline the cons side so it's
like if you agree with this this is what
you'd think if you disagreed with this
this is what you think and I divide the
students into groups it's like four
people per group
okay.you for our pro you for our con
you've got 20 minutes to make a pro
argument you've got 20 minutes to make a
con argument we'll go around the table
and we'll see who you know will will
have each group rate the other and we'll
see who comes out on top well what you
want to do as an educators you want to
you don't want to put forward a specific
point of view not not when you're not
when what you're trying to do is to
discuss a contentious issue right what
you want to do is teach people how to
take an argument apart and formulate a
response and to do that it's actually
extraordinarily useful to arbitrarily
assign positions to people it's like I
don't care what you think you're pro on
this topic generate an argument and what
that what that does is it vastly widens
people's conceptualizations of the
argumentative space because most really
contentious issues gun control abortion
those sorts of things there is a lot to
be said on both sides they wouldn't be
contentious issues otherwise I think
there are many issues that don't go away
well why well because they're so complex
they don't they don't lend themselves to
two to easy unitary solutions one of the
things you want to learn if you're
educated is that on any complex subject
there's a lot to be said and that you
know you're going to come out that with
your particular ideological bias let's
say your temperamental bias maybe even
even you might even come up with at it
with things you've actually thought
about although that's pretty damn rare
but you need to learn just exactly how
localized your viewpoint is theirs
psychology experiments that demonstrate
this quite clearly so imagine that you
come into my lab and I ask you whether
you're pro or pro-abortion or prolife
and I get you to rate that on a scale
maybe you say well on a scale of 1 to 10
I'm 8 pro-life and I say ok now you you
have to write a 500-word essay that's
opposed to your position ok that's
that's the experiment and then I bring
you back two weeks later and I ask you
to rate your position on the same scale
it will have shifted substantially to
the position that you delineated in your
written report and the reason for that
is that most people's arguments are
unbelievably shallow they're not
arguments they're just perceptual biases
that's that's one way of thinking about
them and and if you get people to
delineate out the space in any rigorous
manner then their attitudes shift what
you really want if you're going to
engage in a discussion about say
something like gun control is you want
to be familiar with the entire range of
arguments deeply familiar and have some
respect for them you know I mean there's
it's pretty clear that guns kill people
they're dangerous but then it's also not
self-evident that the only entities that
should be allowed to be dangerous are
the state entities so there's things
that can be said that are intelligent
across that entire line of that entire
distribution of opinion and if you're
educated then you should be conversant
with the entire range of opinions now as
an it so that's one approach as an
educators to teach people how to analyze
an argument and to formulate their
opinions but you you do people a great
service by teeth that's teaching them
how to think not what to think but how
to think now you know when I when I do
when I lecture in my psychology courses
which is a different approach let's say
I take a position on the literature
because I have to like there's no being
neutral about the literature what am I
gonna do pick random studies it's like
that isn't how people work I have a body
of knowledge and it stems partly from my
biases and from my temperaments but it's
an informed body of opinion but what I
present it to the students has is like
look this is my take on the literature
that doesn't mean I'm right it means
that I'm I'm an informed observer I'm an
informed singular observer and what I'm
doing then is modeling how an informed
singular observer would deal with a
complex body of literature so it's
partly in that role I'm not exactly
providing facts and I'm not exactly
teaching people how to think
I'm saying if you're a psychologist
research psychologist and you want to
engage with the literature here's one
way that you would do it and so then I'm
a model and I'm a model of a way to be
in a particular domain now that doesn't
mean that you have to emulate me you
know from top to bottom but at least you
have a sense of what it's like to be a
person doing that and so that's and
that's a different form of pedagogy
[Music]